bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors une situation
catastrophique dans les hôpitaux c'est
ce qui est dénoncé par ou de collectifs
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'ils se rendaient
différents témoignages des soignants
notamment en pédiatrie expliquez-nous
ans la situation sur place concrètement
concrètement il manque du personnel
partout donc c'est du bricolage au
niveau de chaque hôpital où on déplace
les soignants comme des pions d'un
service à un autre ou alors les appels
sur le pendant leurs congés en leur
demandant de s'ils peuvent revenir
travailler et on n'arrive pas à réouvrir
les tous les services qui ont été fermés
pendant l'été pour que les hospitaliers
puissent partir en vacances bon c'est
une situation qui existait déjà avant le
coc vide donc il faut pas tout mettre
sur le coup vide je tiens à le préciser
mais c'est une situation qui s'est
encore aggravée et notamment en
pédiatrie comme vous l'avez dit mais
également dans toute la france il y
avait des services d'urgence qui ferment
et on sait que c'est une des portes
d'entrée de l'hôpital donc derrière
c'est c'est l'hôpital qui est menacée et
certains services de l'hôpital alors ces
termes tu rien qui semble poser problème
au gouvernement la ministre à
l'autonomie en profite bourguignon je
viens d'en parler a sur elle qu'il n'y a
pas de tri mais reconnaît des tensions
déjà si les soignants et le gouvernement
ne font pas le même constat ce sera
difficile d'avancer
forcément ce jeu c'est clair qu'on n'est
pas du tout entendu quand on reporte des
des opérations au bloc opératoire
on est en train de choisir
quelle opération va reporter et laquelle
on va pas reporter alors après on peut
toujours se se mettre d accord sur le
terme de tri mais là il ya un choix qui
est fait pareil pour une place
d'hospitalisation quand ya pas assez de
places d'hospitalisation
on est obligé de choisir qui on
espitalier
voilà alors il ya certains soignants qui
parlant justement de situations inédites
notamment avec la bronchiolite on sait
que cette année elle est virulente mais
cela a été crescendo on peut pas dire on
en arriver là du jour au lendemain
non non déjà avant je le répète avant la
pandémie
on avait déjà des situations d'urgence
au niveau de la pédiatrie où on est on
était par exemple en ile de france ont
obligé de transférer les des enfants
dans d'autres régions et vous imaginez
les prises de risques que c'est et vous
imaginez la la la souffrance des parents
et leurs inquiétudes donc c'est déjà des
choses qui existaient mais elles sont
forcément exacerbée aujourd'hui parce
que parce qu'on n'est pas entendue on
n'est pas entendu sur les salaires on
n'est pas entendus sur les les les
embauches il faut embaucher massivement
et on n'est pas entendus sur le fait
qu'il faut arrêter de fermer des lits
elle justement le manque de lits et de
personnel finalement le manque de moyens
humains et matériels c'était le sujet en
principal du ségur de la santé
aujourd'hui on a du mal à constater ses
effets
pas du tout il n'y a aucun effet
soi-disant le choc date rit-il
d'attractivité n'est n'est pas du tout
présent moi je parle régulièrement avec
des collègues ils sont énormément de
collègues veulent partir ils acte quand
ils viennent d'arriver ils attendent
d'être titularisé pour pouvoir partir
il n'y a aucune attractivité bien au
contraire le management est extrêmement
délétère on déplace comme je vous ai dit
les les soignants comme des pions on
leur accorde pas leurs congés annuels
après un an et demi de pandémie quand on
vous dit du lundi au vendredi en vous à
corbeaux jours mais le week-end il faut
que vous échangez avec un collègue c'est
pas sérieux qui a envie de vivre comme
ça il faut tout changer le management de
nos hôpitaux et c'est vraiment urgent à
nicolas cassieu las merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes aides soignants et membre du
comité d'administration du collectif
inter vengeance persia